health officials in several states are
urging people to cancel outdoor events
amid several cases of a rare deadly
mosquito-borne illness so far this year
at least 22 cases of eastern equine
encephalitis virus have been reported in
six states five people have died
including three in Michigan Dean
Reynolds reports from Kalamazoo I never
thought that this would happen to our
family it's so rare but it did Ron ab
agent spent her father stands 79th
birthday by his bedside Wednesday at
this hospital in Battle Creek Michigan
an active man who golf three times a
week Stan first developed flu-like
symptoms he slipped into a coma and they
had to put him on life support how long
has he been in a coma three weeks on
Monday his doctors said a blood test
confirmed he had eastern equine
encephalitis it's just one little tiny
mosquito and it can cause horrible
neurological effects three people in
Michigan have died and another four have
gotten sick people are at increased risk
from serious complications from Triple E
are less than the age of 15 and greater
than the age of 50 there is no vaccine
against Triple E and no specific
antiviral treatment health officials are
urging people who live in affected
counties to consider canceling or
rescheduling outdoor events at dusk peak
biting hours for mosquitoes until the
first frost if that's not possible
folks should be wearing insect repellant
wearing long sleeves in Massachusetts
the state with the highest number of
confirmed cases officials are taking a
more aggressive approach spraying in the
air and on the ground
Ronn of agent and her son are holding on
to hope her father will survive and
wants others to take the warning
seriously are you changing your behavior
as a result of this oh absolutely
our whole family now wears bug spray
from the time we get up until the time
we go to bed for CBS this morning Dean
Reynolds Kalamazoo Michigan